[موسيقى]
العمل بالاسود هو بالتاكيد غير قانوني
كليا ونفتشون موجودون للكشف عن الاشخاص
الذين يعملون دون تصريح لمعاقبه العامل
غير المسرح به وايضا صاحب العمل او الشركه
التي لديها موظف بالاسود نحن بالطبع في
حاجه الى مزيد من عمليه التفتيش ونحتاج
ايضا الى التاكد من ان العقوبات راضعه
[موسيقى]
الحكومه لا تفعل ما يكفي منذ مده طويله
والموارد الممنوحه لسلطه تفتيش العمل غير
كافيه وسياسه الحكومه في غض البصر عن بعض
الحالات سمحت بازدهار العمل غير القانوني
[موسيقى]
سيتم مناقشه قانون في بدايه السنه القادمه
وهذه خطوه جيده الذين لا يملكون اوراق ان
يقوموا بتحسين وضعهم فالدوله الفرنسيه
وضعت خطه يوجد هناك من انواع من الاعمال
العمل في البناء العمل في المطاعم في
الفنادق في التنظيف في مساعده
كبار السن في البيوت الممرضات
والحتى السائقين الكميونات والباصات انه
كل من يقوم بهذا العمل
يذهب الى البرج كثير من منطقه الشرطه
ويقوم ويقول انا اعمل وعندي عقد عمل سوف
يعطونه الاقامه